[Music]
here's how the survey works we asked
three celebrities to complete a phrase
our first phrase was I think in another
life I was probably Donald Trump said a
Roman Emperor Hillary Clinton said a
famous explorer Bernie Sanders said a
loose pile of white yarn the rumor the
rumor that Leonardo DiCaprio was raped
by a bear in the revenant was started by
Leonardo DiCaprio said an overzealous
publicist Tom Hardy said a misinformed
studio executive Smokey Bear said me I
tap that look at his face not at all
apologetic my favorite part about this
Christmas was Marco Rubio said watching
my kids unwrap their presents Jeb Bush
said watching my wife unwrap her
presents Donald Trump said watching my
old wife unwrapped my new wife I come
from a mixed marriage because Halle
Berry said my mom is white and my dad is
black Jake Gyllenhaal said my dad is
Swedish and my mom is Jewish
Vin Diesel said my dad is fast and my
mom is period
[Applause]
okay all right
but I'm sorry I know people like that
but that's so stupid I was born with a
face that says Danny Trejo wrote don't
mess with me
Martin Short wrote let's have fun Ted
Cruz wrote I think I had some bad
scallops my favorite historical figure
is Alec Baldwin wrote Abraham Lincoln
because of his brave determination Neil
deGrasse Tyson said Isaac Newton because
of his revolutionary thinking Larry King
said Christopher Columbus because he had
let me steer the ship very old my
favorite thing about spring is Russell
Brand said getting outdoors again
Melissa McCarthy said seeing the flowers
in bloom Mitch McConnell said crawling
onto the beach with my fellow turtles to
layer
and quietly and finally I am frequently
told I resemble mark wahlberg said Matt
Damon Elizabeth Banks said Jennifer
Aniston Steven Tyler said a horny
feather duster
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography